the final season of better call saul
premieres april 18th which will be a big
deal we're going to finally let go of
that character yeah
are you happy to bury him are you happy
to say goodbye to saul or um are you
having um well i can't wait for people
to see this final season it's great i
think the writer's really delivered and
it's so much that happens in it so
um yeah april 18th
we start rolling and showing it to
people and uh you know i i haven't
really said goodbye to it it's been
going on so long in my life howard i've
been playing this guy for like
15 years
you've been nominated for best actor
four times but you have not won is it
time for you to win the emmy i was told
it is time yes i was told
it's time by the way better call saul
has been nominated for 39 emmys yeah and
has not won one and that come on emmy
people there's something wrong with
these people i don't know something
wrong i mean what is going on you better
you better get on that i don't know what
you're doing and what about the final
show bob you know because the final show
is always a big deal did you do it right
i think we did i think that that's a
killer ending boy it's good it's not a
spoiler but i would say that one of the
cool things about the final season is
the two shows breaking bad and better
call saul have never been more
connected than that oh in this final
season i had such a good idea for the
ending of uh better call saul i was
going to call you up but i said who am i
i what's the idea
saul versus godzilla i like it you know
i love it and and uh it would be
unbelievable yeah people would go wild
of course they'd have to tell you the
backstory of godzilla and the
traumatic childhood and
that's why he's a monster because you
know right i was totally wrong on